parmi ces sanctions il ya une
interdiction de survol de l'espace
aérien pour les compagnies russes mais
aussi pour les jets privés il devient
donc très compliqué pour la population
de se déplacer quelles sont les
conséquences alors qu'on apprend à
l'instant que la russie interdit à son
tour les compagnies aériennes de 36 pays
en représailles aux sanctions on en
parle avec gérald feldzer bonjour s'être
consultants en aéronautique
vous êtes aussi ancien pilote de ligne
président d'aviation sans frontières
donc on vient d'apprendre la réaction de
la russie à d'interdire donc les
compagnies aériennes de 36 pays comment
ça va se passer comment se passe une
interdiction de survol est ce qu'il ya
une possibilité que les compagnies ou en
jet par exemple haye contre cette
interdiction
leurs noms et chaque pays est
responsable de fond n'est pas aérien les
fans aérien ça va du sol jusqu'à la
troposphère et à lire vingt mille mètres
en gros et donc
il se trouve que là bas tous les pays
d'europe comme
ils se sont entendus c'est une grande
première pour appliquer la même là même
la même restriction donc en principe les
russes pas sous peine d'être intercepté
par des chasseurs de chaque pays que ce
soit l'allemagne la pologne puis la
france et puis avec eux des codes qui
sont connus internationaux de formation
suivez-nous on bat des ailes et puis
ensuite on sur le train il faut de poser
ici etc etc pas là et s'il devait y
avoir une attaque ça serait plutôt avec
des missiles qu'avec des avions